get him buddy
get him get him get him shit
no he's right
he's about to bail
[Music]
get him get him get him get him get him
get him get him buddy
get him get him get him shit
man jump your hands out now
hands down hold up
don't put your hands out good boy hold
up put your hands out now
keep them out
hey shut up
get him get him get him get him get him
get him chef get him get him get him bob
get him
hands down another
hand off right now hands up right now
put your hands out now
put yourself right now okay put your
fucking hands up
oh
where are they at
mickey
okay
everybody watch my corners for me
make sure people don't come out
get up kevin come on now
[Music]
off
up
off
kevin you're under arrest partner
to a
tell them we need 51.
fast
yeah he's running
here
we're northbound near the grass
okay
ah
where'd he go
[Applause]
here buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
sheriff's officers
find a man
thanks for joining us
bro you better come out of that closet
i'm about to open the door through the
dog in there
don't tell me you're in there you better
come out
last warning
[Music]
show me your hands
please
okay
stay right there
[Music]
god
[Music]
drop the gun
here
you're gonna get bit by the dog
10 15.
[Music]
good
here here
here here here here
take him take him
[Music]
don't fuck with my dog
[Music]
wait for it
fly
that good boy
that's the only one
oh
all right
oh
[Music]
oh
oh